two
[Music]
let's do this guys yeah let's go
we are here
it is the leftovers we've got a great
show today
we are
bringing the heat
the righteous justice yeah come on now
that's right
that's right that's right brother oh i
know i gotta work on that that's even i
just i just wanna let you know that you
are
you are co-hosting with
a person who is uh
unfortunately uh outed as uh making
money online
i'm disgusted
hussein
who says hussain keemstar oh yeah
whatever your name is and then
alex jones calls you pecker as your last
name so yeah
it's your alias that's right that's me
hussein pecker
so um you know yeah there was a big
twitch leak oh yeah which by the way
round of applause to amazon security on
that one twitch yeah i don't know how
these huge tech companies manage to leak
their data every [ __ ] week but here
we are yeah you were number one trending
every time it comes up people are like
goddamn yeah no it's it's awesome i i
was really owned this time i mean this
time they got me they got me good
it's just funny because like so what
ended up happening is there was a
massive leak they have the entire source
code of the platform like they have they
have so much data and they just dumped
it and they said it was part one it was
dumped on 4chan
not on pole but still
um and they did it because they said
that twitch was very toxic it was a
toxic culture you're unfortunate saying
that so i don't know
yeah yeah i'm talking about like the
corporate culture or
no streamers no i think they they mean
like i suspect they mean like you know
hot tub oh for real i don't i mean i i
kind of don't know i i don't know why
they would people think people suspect
it might be an inside job like a
disgruntled former employee because like
the amount of information that's like
available is insane
what i'm wondering is if they have
emails which i'm hoping they do are we
gonna finally figure out what happened
to dr disrespect dude
that's what i want to know as well but
also at the same time if they have
emails like i'm kind of cooked
you know what i mean you think so why
not like internal documentation or
anything like that but like i i if they
have emails it means they have like so
much information that what was it like
you about
i mean we get paid out by twitch you
know what i mean like that's you got
social security numbers and like a lot
of different things that that shit's out
there already yeah well
i hope not it's out there bro they've
got it
bank account information you know uh all
this other stuff it's just
it's not great to have all that oh they
they've got all that passwords are
passwords are also luckily uh you know
uh hashed and encrypted yeah so
hopefully that is not a part of the leak
well so it turns out that uh
hassan here hussein pecker
did pretty good on twitch
but that wasn't a secret because you
were
displaying your do you mind if i show
this no i don't i mean it's it's out
there yeah yeah no i are you embarrassed
at all i mean i know that your your subs
you display
yeah i'm i'm super embarrassed by it but
i feel like the you were already up
front about this information so i don't
know why people were no like it's a
simple calculation no it's the thing
that people love to do where they're
like um
they just
none of the people that are upset at me
has have ever watched me right because
if you do you would know like this is
something that i acknowledge this is
something that i
uh openly show in an effort to be as
transparent as possible right
um
so if you've ever watched me like my my
fans my community they're like they love
this they think it's funny they meme
about it now stop
but
if you've never watched me then you're
like
wow like we leaked it you've seen only
like the hot takes
this is
leaked this guy wow he's making a lot of
money doing this and it's like well yeah
i'm i'm making a lot of money in the
form of uh subscriptions five dollar a
month subscriptions for content that's
otherwise free
um
uh people will always be like oh well
you know that's you're you're banking on
parasocial relationships is like
i literally if you've ever been in my
chat if you're ever in my community i
don't read donations i don't read
subscriptions
uh and that's not like a way that you
can interact with me if you want to
interact with me you write in the chat
it's the most democratic way possible
all you need to do is follow for 10
minutes there's a 10 minute follow to
you know combat raids and stuff
but other than that like you write
something doesn't matter if i have 3 000
people in there way back in the day
doesn't matter if i have 30 000 people
40 000 people i will very likely read it
i'm a sniper
um and i try to i try to make that as
democratic as possible like i want to i
want to hear from everyone i don't care
i don't want to like pay while uh
anything in that respect that's pretty
impressive that you're able to garner so
many um
subscribers
without like reading out messages and
stuff but yeah
because they're not bad at all it's not
that at all people see me as
a leftist voice that has either helped
radicalize them or helped communicate
their thoughts better
and they want to support it they're like
i like what this guy's doing is pretty
amazing i want to give him five dollars
we we mapped it out last year
because i was live 42 percent
of the entire year
like literally like possible i just
would stream for you know 14 hours and
then i would go to sleep and then i'd
wake up another stream again because
covet i had nothing going on
my dog passed away i was like very
lonely
i needed it it's all good i i needed a
i needed a sense of community you know
what i mean i needed like something to
keep me
focused
and you know wake up in the morning and
do something and and that community that
i was able to build helped me
with that
so i was live for 42 of the year and it
came down to if you purchased a five
dollar a month subscription which you
don't have to because everything is free
literally free yeah um
it came down to two cents an hour
know what yeah you were they were paying
they were paying you they were paying
yeah if you bought you know a five
dollar subscription and you watched like
all of my content through 2020 you paid
me two cents an hour sex lines are way
more expensive than that that's what i'm
talking about that's right yeah that's
what most people are understanding
impressive like i mean you you're number
13. that's got to feel pretty good at
least
i mean
not necessarily i didn't even crack the
top 10 dude [ __ ] [ __ ] broke damn
for a nice loser it's it's funny because
like i mean critical role is a is up
there in the top but they're like a
critical role so they're like they're
like a dnd company they make like
professional dnd campaigns if i'm not
mistaken dungeons and dragons yeah
so they're it's like totally separate
they have a super it's like a network
yeah they're like a network there's a
couple of chuckles xqc is number one
streamer yeah and that's some cheddar
cheese right there boy yeah
so wow so but the thing about xqc and
the think about summit anything about
like someone like myself as well on that
list is that like 8.5 million xuc made
for people listening
yeah between
it's a two-year period yeah between
august 2019 until october 2021
and um
the thing is excuse me number one
on the platform
in that entire duration right
and throughout that process he has had
an average of like anywhere from i think
back in 2019 like 30 000
all the way to now like consistently 60
000 and in certain instances like up to
a hundred thousand concurrent live
viewers
that's insane like that's like tv show
level that's yeah bigger than a tv show
and it's live for all day yeah and he's
live for 10 hours every day people in
traditional media on television pulling
the numbers that people online do are
you know
multiple ways yeah way way way more
caked up there's a lot more advertising
stuff that goes into it um and this is
just the payout stuff for
subscription and ad revenue so this is
what like twitch is paying you right
so
for someone like myself that's that's
pretty much like all of the money that i
make because i make all of my money from
the subscriptions and also the ad
revenue even though i used to never run
ads but i was isn't that ad revenue
anything significant because when i was
on twitch it was very little i i did not
notice at first i didn't realize
and i was like why the [ __ ] am i making
a lot more money now my subscription no
i think it's it's a i don't think it's
as high as youtube maybe but
but that i also don't run a lot of ads
so
okay so but it is something because yeah
when we would do it back in the day it
was like
you know you would get like 50 bucks and
i would have like 20 000 people watching
and i was like i negotiated my contract
with twitch yeah to lower my ad density
to like physically the lowest i could do
well without them being like okay [ __ ]
off i used to never run ads until this
but then my you know contract came up
and i got
uh my agency to negotiate it down to 60
seconds
uh per an hour of content and that's
like
i mean that's nothing in comparison to
youtube that's nothing in comparison to
tv obviously
um
and uh and at first i hated it and now
i'm just like it doesn't even matter i
mean i turned it into a game right
but
even with that even running 60 second
ads like to a 30 000 uh live 40 000 live
concurrent viewer audience like you it
adds up it makes a lot you add up a lot
of money there interesting so the point
i'm trying to make is like xqc
is is you know profoundly
uh uh wealthy from tv streaming uh he
does now he used to make fun of me all
the time and now he like runs they all
they all run [ __ ] way more ass than i
do which ironically they used to always
say i run the most ads but
what i was trying to say is like
so he's profoundly wealthy but he's also
like he works in he's saying
he's he's top of the game yeah he's like
literally never had a screaming field
and neither do i like we just don't stop
streaming thing is the top in any field
is gonna make a lot of money yeah if you
look at the top of the field in youtube
they
bro it you would think it's not any
youtuber you know for example like the
stuff that ryan's toy reviews ryan's toy
reveal ain't [ __ ] anymore i thought
wasn't he back in the day he's still
huge but there's other channels because
now my son he's
he's over two he's gotten into all the
youtube content
and um he loves this one baby boss and i
get fascinated because i go man because
the views
you'll click on a video and it's got
like a billion views
so i go okay what so go baby bus social
blade and i start looking up all the
stats just out of sheer curiosity
and you start doing the numbers and your
mind just explodes because
first of all
um okay that's a wide estimation
hundred and thirteen thousand to one
point eight million dollars a month they
don't know what they're talking about
that for for kid shows the cpm tends to
be higher yeah
so you're looking at at least ten
dollars cpm okay
and now you're looking at let's see
let's come down here oh they're having a
rough uh they're having a rough time
here guys not a good month for babies
they had their best month was a billion
views
in may in one month in one month that's
just insanity a billion uh views at 10
would be i think 10 million dollars in
one month
right dan
yeah right yeah yeah 10 million dollars
yeah youtube is a much larger audience
too that's like that's why it's like
funny when people are like oh my god
twitch streamers are making so much
money and we are like twitch rumors are
making an insane amount of money at the
top of course dude i think it's
fantastic that you guys are you know
back back a few years ago when we were
on twitch people just weren't pulling
people were not
making
money you guys are making top end
dollars now yeah i think part of that is
twitch prime too yeah fantastic love
that daddy bezos thing yeah daddy baited
the bazel box um
and yes
so i i just like you know
people were
not a lot of people were actually like
frustrated at the top content creators
because i think i like basically
took all the hit
like i i'm a magnet for all of that kind
of controversy because yeah yeah that's
a [ __ ] ludwig finding streamers make
money hassan taking the heat for
everyone yeah it's just like asthma goal
was like thanking me he's like i'm so
glad assange is on the platform he's
like everybody just yells at him instead
of us like it's hard to stand up for
yourself and be like yeah i make money
you know so what but i mean that's the
truth it is what it is like we we're
it's just weird because we're a part of
this industry that everyone loves and
everyone's happiness like we don't want
to watch tv we don't want to watch
[ __ ] we don't want to get cable
subscriptions and do all this normal
mainstream [ __ ] all those people would
make way more money than we do so why
does it surprise you when people at the
top of the game entertaining the most
people working super hard are making
money
um i think it's not it's not that it's a
surprise because you know uh
people expect that right
but it's more so just anger that people
feel because they're like well [ __ ]
these guys all they're doing is like
sitting around in their living rooms
talking to a [ __ ] camera watching
youtube that's boomer [ __ ] and playing
[ __ ] uh playing video games i i would
love that job and it is it is right it's
a [ __ ] incredible job
it is one of the best jobs you can ever
have i love it i i love it
i'm profoundly fortunate that's why like
even if i have offers even when i get
offers from like larger media legacy
media publishers stuff like that i'm
like [ __ ] off it's not happening me too
it's like it's the i was there there's
no reason for anyone like us to go to
and have a boss tell you what kind of
content you can make editorial control
over what i can and can't do
when i'm literally speaking to a massive
audience a community that i love
and i i make enough money that i never
have to like worry about anything like
that yeah and can withstand like
additional cancellation or whatever the
[ __ ] you know what i mean if like people
were like we were we're gonna cut them
off
um
um so that's like that that's what it is
and that's why i i make most of my
revenue unlike unlike every other
streamer on there
i don't have a lot of advertising deals
like i do it every now and then i did a
far cry one the other night oh yeah you
know this i have a hard time with ads
regardless
but
um i refuse to do ad deals
like ninety percent of the time on my
twitch stream
uh when advertisers come in
i uh
i don't really do a lot of merch either
like i have uh i'm working on it
currently
but it's been it's been difficult like
you know ethical sourcing of garments
and stuff like that uh but
they're just i mean people are just
making [ __ ] up like they just yeah so i
want to get in anything so they're just
like making stuff up they want to be
angry at me
and and they can't be like angry at it
because it's like people are voluntarily
subscribing for five dollars a month
and they literally don't even get
anything in return because it's
it's [ __ ] free the content is free i
do everything for free not only that but
i give out my ip for free too so there's
like other youtube channels yeah that
just simply take clips from my stream
and post it and they have hundreds of
thousands of subscribers yeah they
really post it before you do yeah they
post before i do sometimes you know so
what was interesting about this list
was that for because a story we've we've
followed is that um
just basically that women are ruining
twitch these uh
thoughts i guess as they call them or
hot tub girls or e-girls there's not a
si i don't correct me if i'm wrong but i
don't see a girl here amaranth is the
top uh where's amaranth amaranth is the
top like female content creator now like
most paid
um but she's not in the top 25. yeah
she's there's there's nobody in the top
25 that's even that's even a woman yeah
and no hot and like maybe she's the only
hot tub streamer so i find that ironic
too about how much people have bitched
and cried and moan about girls on twitch
yeah uh and they're not even on the list
so [ __ ] east [ __ ] to them by the way
side note
um well amaranth and and like elini and
and many other female content creators
like the ones that have only fans like
pop the [ __ ] off on only oh yeah that's
where they make the bulk of their money
exactly but so like that doesn't even
affect these these dudes complaining
about it it's like if you want to go on
it's a whole different platform
but i think pokemon made a good point
about [ __ ] at least people can't over
exaggerate me making a millions off my
viewers anymore she wasn't even like
crack the top hundred yeah she said
she's number 39 i see yeah the thing
with like iman is that so
like she's a massive content creator she
has her youtube stuff and there's the
second part of that where she's like
well i make like a lot of money off
investments and
and things of that nature and you know
merchandising and like ad deals right
so i don't need to like she's like i
don't need to
you know
do like a i don't need to get money from
donations and stuff which i don't even
have like i turn off my tts i never read
it like i said it's not like method to
interact with me
um
but
the
people were yelling at me they were like
why i can't be like pokeman it's like
dude my top donator gave me 35 like the
donations are [ __ ] nothing yeah if
you don't read them off it doesn't yeah
i don't i don't read the donations
there's no like
there's no back and forth people donate
because they want to be heard sometimes
i turn on tts because it's like funny
people make like crack like [ __ ]
jokes and stuff but
most uh like 99 of the stream is off
so
it doesn't even matter i don't even know
how to [ __ ] turn them off but i could
um and then people are like make
investments like i i don't want to
[ __ ]
park my wealth in the stock market like
that's yeah but that's like the people
think that like when you have a few
million bucks it's easy to just be like
here take my money make me money it's
not like that you guys it's really not
but yeah and and most importantly like
part of the reason why the revenue looks
like that
is that
iman doesn't stream as much you know
what i mean she's awesome
love her she's great
but you know that's what happens if you
don't have like if you don't stream as
much you do you don't have as many
subscribers that's how it works
um
i don't stream for you know two days
i
uh i i lose 5 000 subscribers
yeah you just like it's like that you
see it i mean it's not rough it is it it
it is it's i mean it's a lot of people
to stay rel to stay on but but yeah i'm
a side of the game i'm a psycho so i i i
love that like competitive aspect to it
more than anything else
but um but i don't really dude i don't
well i don't stress it it's like what
[ __ ] oh no i have 50 000 subscribers
instead of 55 like that's insane that's
an insane amount of subscribers to begin
with you know
um andy noah said a leak from twitch
shows that hassan hussein pecker
links
tags you of course send all hate here
but like that's not gonna that's not
gonna shake me yeah obviously a popular
far left streamer and socialist activist
earns two hundred thousand dollars a
month this doesn't include the venture
uh revenue earned from other ventures
which it sounds like there isn't really
it was also re uh recently revealed that
he purchased a 2.7 million dollar west
hollywood mansion for shane really
brilliant [ __ ] reporting by andy noah
dude thanks man yeah pecker is mad
it's just weird they're they're like
they're literally just like man this
guy's successful dude i [ __ ] hate
that
like all right thanks dude i don't know
like i don't know what to say
um thank you
for
telling everyone
how successful i've been
yeah the whole thing the whole
consistent uh shaming of you for buying
a house having a good income from twitch
the whole situation is just so odd to me
because
there's nothing inherently wrong with
being wealthy right i mean like there is
a point where
probably upwards towards a billion plus
where it becomes an issue but like
having a few million dollars
tens of millions of dollars in my
opinion is there's nothing wrong with
making that much money nothing
inherently wrong with with socialist
principles either
um
so
here's where uh you and i differ i think
uh-oh so i first of all i believe
that uh it for it's functionally
impossible to generate like
uh a a certain level of income probably
in like
the tens of millions without
um
hiring people
and then
uh
profiting off of their labor it's just a
simple marxian term profit being
profit being theft the difference
between you and i i think is that you
are a capitalist i am not
so when you hire people
um you extract their surplus labor value
in the form of a profit yeah and then
you use that profit for whatever you can
pocket it if you want you can use it
back and reinvest it back into your
business if you want um and someone on
the left someone who is anti-capitalist
would say
i believe that there should be a more
democratic process in the way that that
profit is distributed so for example
i have two editors on my youtube channel
and it's not a full-blown cooperative
corporation because
i'm still the main like service provider
it's not like we're [ __ ] making
pomegranate juice or something or we're
not doing commodity production right
um
but they dictate what they do they
dictate their own hours they dictate uh
what kind of content that they want to
make they guide the direction in its
entirety they guide the direction of the
channel
um so
the the thing that i'm designing
currently
up until recently i was just like paying
them a flat fee that they asked and that
i would just increase whenever revenue
increased because i was like you're not
asking like so i'm just going to give
you more money because the channel's
making more money but now it's gotten to
a point where like the channel makes a
decent amount of money
so um
i'm just going to give them the flat
fleet flat fee plus um half the revenue
overall
okay of the entire channel
and um and not only that but then also
getting your ideas over there dan not
only the [ __ ] revolution back here
not only that but yeah oh yeah we will
um
we will figure out
how to contract out like other editors
give them a cut of your main source of
income why why because they don't touch
the main source of income in any
meaningful capacity the main source of
income in the form of like the twitch
stream is just it's just me
you know what i mean they're just
working on
what i'm creating on twitch and then
adding value to that at what point can
you hire someone to help you
on your main channel without
having to pay them
an enormous amount of money that you
think that like you've you've built this
thing
by yourself
from the ground up
so how can you
ethically hire somebody to work for you
either researching
or
uh yeah let's say let's say researching
preparing stories like we have you know
yeah um how would you pay that i think a
distribution of of profit there
considering like
how unique what we do is because like
you're the content
you are providing the service right
it's not like um you're a factory owner
and you don't really do anything you're
not on the [ __ ] assembly line if
you're a factory owner but when you're
the content creator yourself
you're the one who probably edited the
videos until a certain point and now you
have editors right so but you're still
the one who's like directing the content
and you're still the one that's being
filmed so it presents a unique up unique
problem really from at least up marx's
point of view something that i think
about all the time something that i was
thinking about even before i became this
successful and i never thought i would
is like how do i ethically uh contract
out people or hire people so
um well one thing i do is basically just
ask them like how much do you want to
get paid yeah what do you want my
experience when you ask people how much
you want to get paid especially in this
realm what they'll tell you is
it's fun like they they they think
they're exactly they're used to getting
[ __ ] yeah so like when i ask people
generally what what's your what do you
want to get paid what's your price and i
always pay them what they ask but it but
and then sometimes more you offer more
because you're like that's stupid i'll
pay you more like yeah yeah but in
general if you ask what do you wanna get
paid people are gonna ask you know way
way way way way less than no literally
so i work as well so i add on to it yeah
um but still it's like
so you do so if you made a if you hired
someone to work with you
on your stream you would not pay them a
percentage
no i would i would pay them a percentage
i don't know what like the the adequate
distribution would be and i have no idea
and also part of that is like this is a
double problem for me
it's a problem because i think about the
ethics of uh hiring someone like that
like as a full-time employee
um
and and like how to uh offer them
adequate pay for the amount of value
that they're providing for me right
because that's what labor is labor
creates value there is no value without
labor
um but in my situation there is value
without labor because i'm the labor
right do you see what i'm saying because
we're not like
if you if you were making this chair or
if you were making this desk
and you owned a factory that made these
desks right
you would not be able to make the desk
on your own you would have to hire
someone to make the desk but in my
situation even without anyone else i can
still keep it going right
because i have a community and all that
and
that's that's it's like back and forth
conversations
maybe you're over complicating things in
that
it might make you more hesitant to hire
somebody oh for sure it definitely has
which to me seems inhere inherent issue
with this philosophy because at the same
time you could easily pay someone the
market value
for a job of researching you can even
double it
pay and it's you're going to end up
hiring someone with a fantastic
uh salary
that's probably is still a very small
fraction of your overall income
but like double the market wage let's
say triple even still a small fraction
of your income there's people that need
jobs who want this job who are going to
be happy
sustained getting what they need
financially and that that to me it seems
like there's no there's no problem past
that and actually there is a problem in
thinking and complicating things the way
you do is because you don't get the help
you need and this person doesn't get a
job so that comes that leads me to the
second problem there which is that
i
don't want to manage i'm not a good
manager i'm not a good business owner
and i don't want to do that i worked at
the young turks
i saw how that operated 26 employees it
grew grew grew there was like they
raised money and all this stuff and i
saw the complications that came about
right
and i don't want that i don't want wanna
i don't ever wanna you're just talking
about like one person that helped put
stories yeah together not like uh not
putting together like a
corporate empire no i i totally
understand that so that's why i don't
focus on permanent growth
like most people do
i think that's like baked into
our uh
understanding of the world like that's
baked into your success everyone
everyone does this
i care more about i mean i obviously
care about like revenue streams uh
clearly because money is freedom
uh ultimately
but i care more about sustainability i
care more about just uh having fun and
having
uh being free of editorial control being
free of like any sort of scrutiny or
fear that uh i might get [ __ ]
cancelled or whatever like that's what i
care about more than anything else so i
can i'm perfectly happy doing exactly
what i've been doing
and continuing to do that and if it
grows it grows like a person that i
actually think has an incredible
business model that i really despite
like our disagreements
that i really i guess uh think is is
great
his business model at least is pewdiepie
like i think that the way that he has
been able to
he has a very light touch he works with
like two editors that's it that's what
i'm saying yeah and i i love that i want
that that's precisely and he is also a
workhorse so like yeah but that's what i
that's what i am when i exactly you i
think you guys have that in common but i
was shocked when i found out you didn't
have anyone to help you because it can
help consider i mean it can just be a
huge job it's a win-win that's the thing
it's like some there are times when
capitalism
i personally think capitalism is a great
system i am a capitalist and like the
situation i described is a win-win
everybody's happy right but here's the
thing necessarily
in the
situation they are because there's a
there's a lot of times where capitalism
does exploit labor for sure and like you
look at like walmart and amazon and the
companies like that where they're like
publicly traded and they're serving you
know the interests of their board and
and etcetera then what they do is they
squeeze [ __ ] as tight as
possible without popping them right yeah
but in the case of you being a
capitalist business owner and hiring
someone paying them a good wage that's a
win-win but my my philosophy on
capitalism is that
i would say
in general it's a fantastic system but
i'd also have like a big asterisk next
to it in which i do believe in big
government i do believe in social
programs like there are some
uh
there are some verticals of business
that should not be privately owned like
like jails like healthcare
uh medicine in general you know stuff
like that it should not be
it's just too important to the public
welfare to be run by private businesses
yeah and also i believe that on the top
end and on the bottom end there needs to
be regulations in control and band and
rubber bands to keep
capitalism on the rails because it will
ultimately
um undermine itself it'll undermine
itself yeah and that's what we have in
america is a system since the reagan era
the neoliberal uh reforms during the
reagan era that have like completely
dismantled any sort of anti-trust laws
that we have that have created all of
these oligopolies uh that engage in
price leadership not price fixing but
that has created this like awful system
in which like your utility providers
suck
um your isps suck and there's no way to
like combat that uh they'll get billions
of dollars from the government and then
refuse to [ __ ] actually implement
fiber you know what i mean they'll get
billions of dollars to like improve the
speeds and then they just like don't use
it you know and there's nothing there's
no way to retaliate against that what i
did wanna i did have a specific question
for you i would say that you're a social
democrat and okay so yeah yourself yeah
if that's what your question was going
to be
yeah is that i am a democratic socialist
so i don't
i believe that like ultimately
um a better future is possible
and that
that revolves around originally
initially getting to uh so a social demo
a social democratic america like norway
okay turn america into norway tomorrow
great but that system itself still
uh heavily relies on exploitation of the
third world that system itself still
heavily relies on imperialism uh and and
in order for it to continue
and so much bloodshed that is overseas
that we don't even see so we don't even
think about it or comprehend it and i
think that in order to solve that in
order to especially combat like the
upcoming uh mass migration that is going
to occur as a consequence of the climate
crisis that we're facing for example we
need to uplift the working class all
around the planet and not just
necessarily try to uh through a series
of like patchworks social welfare
programs uh help out
you know our country here and there
because there is no other solution i see
beyond that or fascism well for sure and
that's what's so weird to me when i see
these huge companies and congress
failing to regulate them is that
ultimately like uh late stage capitalism
you kind of as you see it here yeah it's
it's
self-defeating it's self-defeating
because for capitalism to really survive
for society to be healthy and well oiled
you need harmony you need people on the
bottom specifically to feel comfortable
enough and content enough to where
they're not going to start killing
people yeah i mean and that's what
social so that's what welfare states do
some leftists some anti-capitalists hate
uh the welfare state because they see it
as a continuation of the capitalist
system and that's why they don't even
like social democrats i'm not one of
them uh but because i'm a dirty
revisionist as they would say
uh but
i understand the necessity of of
exhausting the state machinations to its
uh to its final conclusion uh while
simultaneously organizing unionizing
making sure that there is uh you know
direct action taking place to make sure
that the the current existing system
that is a capitalist one that is built
to uplift capitalist uh uh commodity
production
for sure
can be dismantled while simultaneously
improving the material conditions of the
working class
and
i guess like the difference is that i
believe that inherently under a
capitalist organization of the economy
there is a very simple contradiction
between the two classes those who own
businesses
and those who work for businesses the
wage
laborers right
if you've ever worked in retail or
anything like that
you want to work
the least amount of hours for the most
amount of pay
your boss on the other hand wants you to
work the most amount of hours for the
least amount of pay it's that simple and
that contradiction is unsolvable
um without or that contradiction is
unsolvable in our current organization
of the economy social democracy seek to
address some of that through price
controls through a sequence of
regulations that you mentioned
um
and unions uh obviously
um which create an opportunity to
collectively bargain for
all uh working-class interests
but uh ultimately it's still
that that exploitation still exists
there and it just moves overseas and if
you can't find someone to exploit or
naturals natural resources to extract
then you create an uh environment that
makes it so that you can exploit and you
can extract natural resources and that's
where imperialism comes in and we've
done this so many times as the united
states of america the hegemonic power in
iran
uh most they wanted to
nationalize the oil industry their own
resources and british petroleum and the
united states was like [ __ ] that we're
not doing that it happened in chile
there was a on 9 11
uh
way back in the day there was a coup
against allende the people of chile
organized
democratically voted in a socialist
leader and they did they did a coup an
america back coup happened all around
latin america happened all around africa
um so
you know we have been
carefully
stopping any sort of like counter to
uh capitalism any sort of economic
organization that even runs counter to
uh capitalism from existing anywhere
that we can actually change the outcomes
uh in without scrutiny and that's why
you see norway and social democracies
uh operate
without a lot of like american
involvement or american influence like
norway's [ __ ] forestry is
nationalized like the entirety of the
extraction industry in norway from
forests
isn't it true that norway has a shitload
of money because they're just fortunate
to be sitting on a ton of oil i mean but
does not help fund their social programs
quite a bit yeah venezuela does too
norway also has forests but the
difference between norway and venezuela
and i love drawing this parallel is that
yeah sure there's corruption of course
um chavez was good maduro not not as
much not great um
and and also brutal as well
but
the difference between norway and
venezuela is that well venezuela
was not allowed to participate in the
global marketplace despite their um
exactly they they get abused by uh the
so you do you think venezuela would be
an uh a norway s country if it wasn't
for intervention from western countries
specifically united states yes if it if
they were allowed if the united states
didn't actively uh that's a [ __ ]
shame yeah i mean ironic too because
it's like such a talking point of the
right to be like social doesn't work
look at venezuela yeah and and my point
always is like cuba is a great example
of this too he's like if it doesn't work
then just like let him [ __ ] exist you
know what i mean and and it'll blow up
on its own why can't you just let these
countries [ __ ] exist and and
participate in the global
economy like why can't you let foreign
capital still come into the country um
why do you have to constantly you know
facilitate business plots in other
countries uh and and you know hype up a
couple of
billionaires moving through the
government you keep saying norway what
do you think about sweden because they
don't have huge oral reserves but
they're also like um i consider a model
country that is uh you know has a strong
economy sweden has more billionaires
than any other country per capita norway
has more billionaires per capita than
the united states as well yeah yeah so
like by the way that flies in the face
of people that say like oh you you can't
be a wealthy and also be so
be socialist it's just that's just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] fantasy the american
enterprise institute back in the day
used to be like norway's not socialist
like and they would literally show that
there is more billionaires per capita
and then
and then people were like okay then
let's do norway they were like okay we
can't do this anymore they're like we
gotta stop saying this oh [ __ ] no uh
actually they're uh yeah don't don't
focus on that
but like socialism in itself inherently
isn't like you can't be
rich
no as a matter of fact it's quite the
opposite that's the that's the [ __ ]
hilarious part about this and there's so
many different kinds of uh marxist
thought and there's constant infighting
so it doesn't [ __ ] matter and
everyone is gonna have their own brand
and then you have the [ __ ] anarchist
too but um and you know we love
nobody loves uh
absolutely obliterating socialists like
other socialists and other
anti-capitalists so um i i don't i try
to not participate in that as much as i
can but
the thing is like
ultimately
socialism or marxism specifically
comes from
having the workers own the means of
production
and get adequately paid for their labor
the value that they provide
so it's literally the opposite of people
being like marxism means you get no
wages and you get abused by the
government and a small fraction of uh
individuals own all the wealth in
society i'm like that's capitalism bro
you're literally describing capitalism
anytime someone is like socialism never
works it doesn't work
and and here's why they're literally
describing capitalism
you know um
yeah because if you look at sweden
richest man in sweden i'm curious i know
the ikea guy is super react
but if you look at sweden they have a
shitload everything's unionized
and the people that work there are make
a lot of money yeah like the bottom
wrong employees make enough money to
pay rent and feed themselves and live a
dignified life
and yet these people are still able to
be billionaires so like the what you
don't see in sweden
how rich is this stefan per persian guy
pearson
what you don't see in sweden is a lot of
of jeff bezos and elon musk
and bill gates yeah our billionaires are
mega billionaires
yeah like being worth four or five
billion dollars is still even different
to me like i actually don't inherently
have
too much of an issue with someone being
a billionaire what i do have a really
big issue with is obscene mega wealth
that just is like
literally
it's it's unfathomable wealth that and
and these people become
like uh
well force of nature unto themselves
like they affect they can affect so much
you may have a billionaire without
exploitation it's just for sure i mean
there are like actually now in the
current state of the economy there are
some labor billionaires i don't know if
you know this concept or not but like
you do have like athletes like cristiano
ronaldo i think or messi that are like
labor billionaires technically so yeah
you have a lot of musicians that are
getting up there yeah they're not
they're you know there are labor
billionaires like lebron james recently
i don't have a problem with
well when you say exploitation of labor
like well there's swedish billionaires
that they're
their employees are part of a union so
with you that exploitation i don't
understand so even that is unions are
not the end-all be-all obviously uh i
think that there is a there is a
there's an argument to be made about um
uh decommodification of uh certain
resources that you also mentioned
uh one of them i believe is shelter i
think that there should be socialized
housing uh these are all even from like
a classical
uh uh not like a marxian economist uh
economist point of view but there's like
classical [ __ ] macroeconomics 101
microeconomics 101 point of view these
are
goods that have inelastic demand and
what that means is like
no matter what the supply looks like you
still need a house
right to survive you need shelter it's
in the maslow's hierarchy of needs like
you you need shelter you need uh
medicine and you need food and these are
uh commodities that at the very least
should be afforded to every single
working-class person around the world
unconditionally by the state
so that they can you know better you
think that we can be a better world in
general like you think that
but the thing is people are entitled
every person is a tuttle to own a house
i think every person should be able to
have a house yes own a house yeah
and so i guess i guess i guess i don't
disagree with that but it's just in the
current way we do like you would need
and actually i i'm in favor of this but
you would need a massive housing
project run by the government because
you would need like really effective
massive buildings built super
efficiently no one's called you know
what that is first of all public jobs
and it's public housing and that's jobs
and that would be a wonderful
opportunity for america i'm actually not
structured i'm i i'm actually i think
that's a fantastic guy and again it
doesn't mean that you can't live in a
[ __ ] nice house in the hollywood
hills i agree there
i agree yeah um
there are like luxury goods that are are
because i i still
if i'm not but the problem is now as a
business owner if i'm not paying my
employee you know a million dollar
salary is that my fault that the
government is not doing public housing
because me as an individual i can't
ensure that my employees all own houses
like it's just it's not possible
yeah i mean well your business also
might not make enough money to be able
to pay every single employee a million
dollars
that's my point yeah no that's not
that's not up to you at all it's uh
i i
the way i look at it is a bottom-up
rather than a top-down approach like
democratizing the workplace as best as
possible
and what that means is like
i would want everyone that works with me
to have as much autonomy over their own
lives as possible
um i think that's like something even
when i was working at the young turks is
something that i [ __ ] despise is like
waking up on monday morning to go to
[ __ ] work even though i was like you
know i i
was doing extra work that i loved on the
side i still
i still hated it i just like because i
didn't have any control over it you know
what i mean i had a designated time that
i had to go into that i had no say on i
had things that i needed to do that
other people were making me do and that
[ __ ] sucks so i wanna i wanna be able
to have that be more collaborative but
the thing i was gonna talk about was
sweden
i mean and this happens all the time
i mean they stopped it but you know
there was a time and place when they
were outsourcing their production and
even uh potentially rumored to use child
labor you know what i mean like they
were using factories romania and the
conditions were wretched this is all the
way back in 1998 of course and the
international federation of building and
woodworkers threatened to boycott ikea
which i care yeah and that is the beauty
of unions by the way if your [ __ ]
multinational corporation decides to
outsource labor to like super cheap uh
and horrible conditions in an effort to
improve their profit margin for their
shareholders you can be like all right
we're [ __ ] stopping that [ __ ] like
guess what
somehow they still make a [ __ ]
shitload of money but the point is like
and i love this it says ikea has
certainly ended child labor practices in
subcontracting factories
although eway prefers to refer to local
legislation pointing out that the
national laws or regulation may permit
the employment or work of persons 13 to
15 years of age or 12 to 14 years of age
on light work so
like
they this is what i mean when i say that
we need to uplift the material
conditions of the working class all
around the world
um some people would say we have done
that
well you know who's done that yeah
[ __ ] china
right uh-oh
yeah well yeah right i mean in china but
like in general it's true that
poverty has greatly reduced around the
world i mean without china without
chinese numbers it's nothing like
straight up you think most that's just
china china no literal people literally
chinese it's like i'm not a dengue
myself but his reforms
and um allowing foreign labor to are
allowing foreign capital to come into
the country and basically saying like we
just have a lot of [ __ ] manpower
we're just gonna throw it at the problem
and we are going to seize all of the all
of the manufacturing and make it so
cheap here in china because of the
material conditions there uh originally
that like
um you know everyone everyone started
making everything all manufacturing
moves over to china
but then
the reason why people's uh conditions
improved in china and they got out of
poverty wasn't because it wasn't just
because foreign capital was coming in
it was also because they were they were
reinvesting
everything back into
high-speed rail back into socialized
housing even though there is a massive
housing problem in china as well um
because you know they have more
billionaires in their communist party
than any other [ __ ] political party
on the planet um
but you know they have a uh they have a
more centralized control over their own
economy
and um ultimately
despite the horrific yellow and
anti-liberal uh
yeah
they're also monsters yeah for sure yeah
like murders monsters there's genocidals
100 percent 100 mass surveillance yeah
um
the the uyghur genocide absolutely
100 i completely agree with that
um what i was referencing specifically
is like how they've been able to that is
interesting though yeah because like you
don't have to do that like you know what
i mean you don't have to
genocide people to be
uh while also simultaneously helping
and uplift your working class they're
doing that because the weird thing about
communism where they demand homogeny
from everyone yeah which is what ends up
you know killing and and just
i think what they want is they see the
uighur muslims specifically in xinjiang
as uh as separatists
and i mean xi jinping has literally said
this it's so [ __ ] insane that like
there's a lot of leftists who get mad at
me for saying this even they defend
china unconditionally but
um
he literally said like oh our mass
surveillance program of muslims we
learned from america like we are
following america's like technique yeah
but
right but that's kind of what russia
russia always says too when they get
caught that's like the classic go-to
it's just like we learned it from you
dad you remember that commercial yeah
i mean
where did you learn to smoke where did
you learn to smoke weed i learned it
from you dad i mean they they they do
though they they definitely um they
definitely adopt american style mass
surveillance and and neither is okay
don't get me wrong but i'm not one of
those people who's like it's okay when
russia or china does it it's not okay
you know only not okay when america does
it like i think it's not okay across the
board
um
you know some people get mad at me for
saying that but i don't like china i
mean i get the social programs
you're a classic uh
empathetic
american dude who
is of course still
going to have a lot of like uh
a lot of that social conditioning
uh that you get in the matrix still you
think or 100
yeah
i don't know i don't know i mean i get
your perspective my perspective is
different on this because i didn't grow
up in america like i saw the
consequences of like american
imperialism and stabilization sure so
that's the reason why like when you ask
people oh oh the greatest threat is
imperialism and i think like our our
foreign policy is insane you know yeah
it's just i just more from a capitalist
perspective
i think
i just i don't know what's maybe i don't
think we're ultimately that different in
our philosophy
in terms of
um
in the short term especially yeah i
i just believe that it's not
simply enough to
uh create robust social democracies in
the western world while we still
continuously exploit and destabilize
nations
in the third world and refuse to allow
them to develop one other way that we do
this is economic imperialism
the imf and the world bank
offer loans which is what china is doing
as well in the one belt one road
initiative now which america [ __ ]
hates
um but uh we offer loans to developing
nations right we as in like the western
uh nations
and then those loans are conditional and
they come with a set of like
consequences where you can't do social
democratic programs and i know this from
turkey yeah they literally are like oh
you want to do this you got to privatize
your nationalized industries you have to
implement austerity measures like can
you imagine you need a [ __ ] loan they
say we'll loan you the money you need
but you can't do social medicine
you can't do you have to privatize
certain key sectors like they put insane
conditions onto it and are these
american companies getting involved in
these private sectors no that's the
second part of that as [ __ ] though and
then the of course foreign capital
seizes all of those uh previously
nationalized sectors we do this with
telecommunication in turkey um
but not only that
but also on top of that they tell you to
implement austerity measures which is
[ __ ] ridiculous um and then on top of
that the loans go back to
private western businesses
you have to yeah you have to literally
use the money that we gave you that
you're borrowing
back on our businesses
and not on yourself that's freak [ __ ]
dude and that's just alone and and that
is like that is a cycle of [ __ ] abuse
that
is so pervasive it happens all the time
and that's the
that's the soft power touch that's the
soft touch kind of imperialism that we
engage in before we talk about you know
having a military base i am i'm i'm
pretty i'm fairly ignorant on all that
kind of stuff and that that does horrify
me yeah you know what else horrifies me
what
the quartering
it's a good segue and also i'm sorry we
like got into really fine it's good we
like deep dove into this it's good i
have no problem doing it i actually been
wanting to
talk about that kind of stuff for a
while so
i enjoyed it
but i think i do need to educate myself
more in terms of like the corporate
financial imperialism of like stuff you
just described
yeah
it's just it's just uh avenues and
methods of control
that are a part of our everyday lives
and the the
like
you can experience it or you can see it
especially if you ever worked like a
normal job like a wage job with a boss
and whatnot you experience that every
single day which by the way goes back to
the original point is why i was going to
say like i understand when people get
mad at me when they're like
this guy is [ __ ] he's a lot of wealth
what the [ __ ] he's a leftist but he has
a lot of wealth this [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you're working at [ __ ] starbucks by
the way shouts out to the unionization
efforts in buffalo um
but if you work at [ __ ] starbucks
which actually is a better work better
pay and better benefits than most other
companies but and you [ __ ] don't like
your life and you hate it and you hate
your boss and you hate what you have to
do every day or if you work in a
distribution facility for amazon and
you're like well this [ __ ] leftist
guy is is making so much money well [ __ ]
him you know i'm i'm suffering every day
i mean that's just low that's just low
tier bitterness it's got i i don't
accept that as valid criticism no i
don't think it's valid criticism i think
you're you're being generous you're
being nice but no i think the anger is
understandable yeah for sure but
obviously people need to people need to
know where to place their anger i could
you know beat my wife and say well i'm
just angry it doesn't make it [ __ ]
understandable or just obviously more
extreme but yeah no i i think that like
um that
ultimately there's just blind
hatred of oh god what a nice thumbnail
blind hatred of the wealthy ultimately
isn't
the worst kind of thing and i say this
is like someone who is [ __ ] wealthy
right it's not the worst thing it's just
you have to figure out where to direct
that i personally hate this blind i
think the blind hatred of the wealthy is
so dumb because they're such a [ __ ]
tearless getting angry at hassan who
makes a few million dollars a year
versus a lot of money still i know it's
a lot of money i'm just saying the
different tiers of wealth is such a huge
deal obviously being worth 10 million
dollars you're set for life you're good
you've got everything you need beautiful
god bless but then you're talking about
billions of [ __ ] dollars like these
people are the [ __ ] problem bro well
and it's not even necessarily like oh
ethan calling other other rich people
out it's like the difference between me
and jeff bezos is like a [ __ ] i'm an
aunt to him well you and i are closer to
homelessness than we are to jeff bezos
by far yeah no that's like literally but
so is donald trump technically that's
how [ __ ] wealthy yet basically you
could be worth you could be worth 50
billion dollars you could be a
billionaire and be closer to broke yeah
then jeff bezos that's how profoundly
wealthy he is yeah and the point isn't
necessarily like he's been able to
accumulate so much amount like this vast
amount of wealth right um the problem
there is it necessarily the wealth alone
it's that how you accumulate that wealth
you can't accumulate that level of
wealth without [ __ ] grossly
exploiting people yeah non-fucking stop
without having people pissing goddamn
bottles and [ __ ] in bags yeah exactly
and that's the [ __ ] issue the other
day and he's not exploited
what i said dan [ __ ] in a bag the other
day and he's not exploited experience
you guys were doing uh squid games yeah
but
that was the point though is that the
point is like how do you accrue how do
you generate your wealth yeah we yeah
jeff bezos and then what do what those
people do with the profound amount of
influence and wealth they have and how
they dictate policy in a system that
already benefits is a system that is
designed to literally create jeff
bezos's you know what i mean right and
and that's why it's like [ __ ]
hilarious when people are like the one
[ __ ] successful out of like
10 socialist like media personalities
uh let's [ __ ] attack the the guy
who's like currently
the most popular socialist personality
like [ __ ] that guy i [ __ ] hate that
guy i get why you're angry at me i
totally understand it but it's misplaced
anger it's stupid but like these other
smaller socialist creators they make
money the same way you do they just have
less people watching them so who what's
the [ __ ] difference between the two
of you the means of earning money is
exactly the same one
that's true that is i i i joke about
that all the time i was i was only
referencing like you know regular
working-class folks who are just like
who feel frustrated but then again
no no i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
people don't leave like actual
organizers we live for them yeah i mean
look actual organizers
and people that like literally put in
the [ __ ] work what are they like
people those people don't those people
don't get mad at me because you know
they they like what i do i hyped them up
what do you think about the quartering
you have beef with him you've ever
talked
i consider him to be so irrelevant that
i rarely ever mention him i mean i call
him the quarter pounder it's like [ __ ]
up i'm fat shaming a little bit but but
it's funny yeah it is kind of funny i
have no problem with that as a fat
person yeah um well you know he peed in
his basement
i heard this i don't know the exact
detail so i'm i'm excited too well let
me let me start with so well first of
all this is the first
conservative media personality to make a
video about us so let's go kind of fun
let's go thank you quarter pounder
and of course he totally lies and takes
it out of context the title is instant
backfire ethan klein and hassan [ __ ]
laugh at people who died of kovid and uh
well let me start by showing you the
compilation uh that he starts the video
with all right moving on
you guys that watched know that we had
like a pretty nuanced conversation about
like who can we laugh at who can't we
laugh at we weren't just blindly
laughing at uh you know poor people
dying of covet who are the victims of
misinformation but watch how he edits
this and kane you give me a little
volume
herman james
oh i [ __ ] it wait
is that not right no no he said herman
are you saying yeah no no it's not you
got that right i'm just saying like
yeah
that's like totally valid and reasonable
to laugh at herman cain that's what i
was going to say herman cain went to
this event well you see how yeah
and straight up and died
like i will make fun of you if you die
i'm going to make fun of you i will
laugh and worst of all you're going to
tap dance on their grave yeah exactly i
will own you like you will be owned
[Laughter]
yeah so he cuts it out just to make it
look like yeah but but that's his thing
but before we i don't even care to be
honest like yeah i don't know
i don't either
uh but basically
before we get into watching this video
just to give you the the ultimate jeremy
lore
um he's of quite a beta actually he's
not he will never be sigma like we are
do you get yourself alpha or sigma
i'm sigma
unshakable frame
right yeah right you can except my back
is [ __ ] up but yes
so what's the point
uh anyway here is the legendary
quartering peeing in his own basement
because he's mad his wife got pizza
without him you never know
beta's [ __ ]
you never know
maybe i'm going to pee in my trash crank
it up crank it up
come on now
this is important i don't know
my wife went out for pizza without me
and i'm angry about it
oh he's drunk i'm gonna win this round
and i'm gonna pee
if i don't win this round i'm gonna pee
in my own basement
i love that he's a women want me fish
fear me hat
women definitely do not want the
quartering
you're saying peeing in your own
basement
is not sexually desirable
he's a king i don't have a bathroom down
here oh we made it
i was ready to pee my pants
i'm ready i i i don't have a toilet down
here all i have is a drain in the floor
i feel like we're gonna have to use it
though i feel like we're gonna have to
use it
this is in a way he's punishing his wife
by destroying his own property oh you're
shocked by this oh okay i'll keep
playing it i've seen this a million he's
so bad
i gotta pee so bad i gotta be so bad
okay so bad [ __ ] get up and pee dude
what the [ __ ] wrong with you
i'm not going to survive this he's like
playing a [ __ ] baby game while
pissing himself dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy i
mean he literally i mean he is actually
one of the dumbest [ __ ]
he's helped yeah
but i don't want to lose
and then the context of it all being
that he's angry at his wife for going
out with pizza without him and notice
how he says i'm going to pee in my own
basement like he's going to destroy his
own property like also you know that
[ __ ] is always peeing in his
basement and his wife hates it because
it's disgusting so he's like my wife's
going out for pizza with me i'm going to
pee in my [ __ ] basement to show her
but i don't understand like wouldn't it
just smell like piss where you [ __ ]
oh it's splashing everywhere it's gonna
stink like this for sure like why the
[ __ ] i just don't understand like i have
to be so bad
oh and he owns a shed that i think his
wife made him buy so that he can go pee
out there
why does he just pee in the toilet
i don't understand he doesn't want to go
upstairs don't you dare talk about water
ah
wash wash think of cold water i mean
this is sad there's no activity in the
chat dude who the [ __ ] watching
quartering play fall guys nobody you see
five people you guys i mean i just like
i i literally don't understand why
anyone would watch this content anyway
this culminates of course i mean he's
really [ __ ] into pee i i mean he's
currently he's owning like don't don't
talk about what 13 year olds don't talk
about water on the internet on a [ __ ]
baby game while pissing himself it's
perfect
don't talk about it i think there's a
point here where he here it is i'll fast
forward a little bit okay the difference
between the 13 year olds that are
playing fall guys though
and this guy is that they probably piss
in the bathroom you sure they do yeah
you know when they need to pee they're
like okay well i guess i gotta go pee in
the bathroom this [ __ ] was like
no i'm gonna pee in my [ __ ] basement
dude
what a psycho here it here comes the
moment of crisis he owned the lips
pretty hard with this one i think
you so at this point
yeah you can hear him peeing if you put
on the headphones he's peeing he's
standing up and pissing on the floor of
his phone bro he literally did not move
far away from his [ __ ] desk he just
got out he's peeing next to his dad i'm
losing my feet away from it
so just this i like to just bear in mind
the person we're dealing with
um at that point is over
yeah so the debate ends here yeah you
you pissed in your [ __ ] basement
that's so crazy so anyway i figured we
would enjoy some uh the quartering the
quarter brainer
i suspect he's an anti-vaccine just heat
in my basement for sure
uh judging by you know
i don't know if he's an anti-vaxxer but
he's pro he's one of those guys who's
like i'm pro-free
hippo rights baby yeah yeah
anyway whatever he is uh who cares what
a piece of [ __ ]
what's going on everyone jeremy here
from the core volume and i don't think
it's any secret that i've had you know
my critiques of other content creators
at times and um i don't think i've
always been the best
in particular and in terms of my hot
takes and not always been fair and i
think that wow you know after seeing
this podcast with uh ethan klein and
hassan [ __ ] uh i i think i actually got
some good out of it
i decided that i need to try to be
better um especially with my twitter
activity uh reduce that and um and just
be less vindictive and awful because i
don't want to run into
what uh ethan klein has become uh it was
just a just a really sad display of um
two multi-millionaires
what's up yeah he survived jelly bean
this is the thing he mentions the wealth
but there's no
irony there's no criticism of it it's
just they're rich also this is this man
is not a socialist he is pro-capitalism
yeah what's up you should be [ __ ]
on your knees kissing my feet because
i'm rich [ __ ] yeah that's looking at me
that's the thing i never understand it's
like people will literally come into my
chat and like defend their [ __ ]
workplace conditions and their bosses
and [ __ ] and they're like you're [ __ ]
rich it's like okay like
all right if i have all these ill-gotten
[ __ ] gains in the form of like people
voluntarily giving me [ __ ]
subscriptions they like the content that
they're consuming
um then you know the system is i guess
fundamentally broken maybe you should do
something about it you know what i mean
well if he's a capitalist he needs to
worship my [ __ ] feet i agree he's
pro-business kiss my feet [ __ ]
go pee in your basement for me look this
is why i always say to people when they
when they're like socialism but you're
using an iphone it's such an idiotic
[ __ ] argument but also like
okay well you you claim to be
pro-capitalist and yet here you are
failing at capitalism what's up do you
have a deed to the factory dude where's
your capital yeah show me your [ __ ]
happiness capitalism yeah i roll at it
sucks dude i [ __ ] rule at it you suck
at it yeah i'm deep
now
you know the basis for this is like haha
hardy har har har
you know somebody who was anti-poke died
i just don't get that i don't understand
that mentality
i think well again
we weren't just i think even you were
like i don't like laughing at random
people
like we were very open about that so
it's a very bad faith argument from
those well the thing that he cut in the
beginning was me literally saying like
look the other side of this argument is
that
i want the fear of getting owned by libs
uh to
be able to go get vaccinated yeah
exactly like
and he clipped that of course out of
context
yeah it's sick
uh
and you know look sick if there's
somebody out there that was that is like
actively spreading bad information and
people are getting heard of it and then
they then karma gets them i can
understand that he agrees with us that's
what's the whole point
that was literally the whole point of
our segment and he he openly agrees with
it
i don't get he did a whole [ __ ] thing
don't be ethan and and hassan they are
bad people yeah i mean i mean who cares
those people [ __ ] hate us regardless
man like i don't think he [ __ ] did
the same thing he says you can laugh at
people's pretty bad info yeah that's
what we said that's my those my favorite
things when people are like uh i agree
with this guy but i'm gonna act like i
disagree with him while saying the exact
same thing he's saying that's what he's
doing yeah well no he's doing a total
straw man where he's like they're
[ __ ] going to hospitals where people
are dying and spitting on their corpse
as they are
put out in a body bag i did that last
week yeah
it is fun it's so much fun
dumb
yeah and then if you go forward here
i'll play a little bit more for you
but you know
spitting up an entire podcast for
talking about for like a half an hour
laughing at people who who died i don't
think you watched it um i don't even
know what a lot of people do is they
find the highlight and they see the
title and then they make a whole video i
don't think you watched our video
i was i love that you know yeah you
didn't like this guy
he's uh he's so funny he wasn't a part
of your everything you know he's still
maybe if you go a little bit further
just because i don't i don't really
think he's worth the weirdest part about
it is that like quartering is not very
good at what he does because like i feel
like there is a
he can't shut off that part of his brain
that
allows him to go like full [ __ ]
propagandist for some weird reason maybe
he's like too stupid to be a sociopath
you know what i mean
we're like we're like just [ __ ] lie
dude dude like why are you
like i don't i don't get it like just
just say that the vaccine is fake he's
just dumb yeah just say that the [ __ ]
vaccine is fake and it makes you gay or
something and like that's somehow wrong
or whatever and well he would get banned
if he said that first of all oh yeah
that's true i guess they do that they're
banned
but he said he's going to do it like
stephen crowder does complain about the
censorship crowder's smart though he's
got like that he's like uh
he's an advanced racist do you know what
anything like he like we were talking
about last week he's got that high level
racism
oh yeah i think the crowder is just dumb
i mean i guarantee you crowder or uh
quartering's just an idiot
steven crowder does not pee in his own
basement i guarantee that man uses a
toilet you got no glass no
yeah so he said he's been inspired to
be able to be a better person here's
some of his recent thumbnails feminist
rage
it's so funny because like bro are you
[ __ ] 20 21 dude are we really still
doing it yeah no he's trying so
desperately to bring back gamergate like
he's just like that was a good time for
him i think please like please i need
that so bad guess what the next one is
let's see
gamergate
this is from like two days ago i'm not
kidding gamergate tv series bro it's
like there was a point in time when yeah
look at this soy face right here yeah
there was a point in time like everybody
was like riled up i don't even know
anything about [ __ ] gamergate like i
don't know what happened right uh i
don't want to sorry i was
i'm just not interested okay i know a
little bit but not interested
um
ultimately like
there was a lot of people that was into
there was a lot of people that were into
this stuff back then
and now all uh the anti-issue
compilation people that used to pop the
[ __ ] off back in like 2015 2016
are
just they are they all look like
quartering they're all like [ __ ] neck
bearded
look like quartering bro yeah they all
[ __ ] piss in their basements and
they're so sad and so desperate to like
bring back that just like
energy random [ __ ] rad lives on there
yeah this this is the level of content
though feminist rage gamergate and then
by the way epic meltdown he's using the
same women he's been using the same
woman as thumbnail this was like a meme
from like
2015 he must be using the same
yeah by the way
that was a kind of a weird take i wasn't
sure about that i couldn't tell if sarah
silverman was like [ __ ] joking or not
i i didn't understand that like was that
a joke i i i don't know i don't think so
was it can you someone pull up the
jewface thing like i'm genuinely curiou
was she i didn't think that she could
have been joking that that's so wild to
me is like
but she so uh sarah silverman by the way
his thumbnail game is so crazy bro i
mean look at this [ __ ] yeah he it's not
great it's just just bad yeah
um
here let's so silva sarah silverman said
she wants jew face to end um obviously a
shout out to blackface and other
minority groups being portrayed by white
people or people not i literally thought
she was joking i can't believe this so
sarah silverman calls for an end to jew
face in hollywood representation matters
actually there's a video to it so we can
actually
um
tell for sure like what is there is
there like a
representation problem with like jewish
people in hollywood and also i do i
think for the most part when jewish
people are cast in a role
it's usually jewish people that play the
role too
i mean there's a few notable differences
i would say but in in what she talks
about she cites some specific examples
why the [ __ ] want to learn
oh
i'm not sure i really want to watch this
video it's always genteels
i really want to i'm sorry but like
look um obviously anti-semitism is a
gigantic problem still in in this day
and age and you know uh
it's it's at the heart of like every
[ __ ] psychotic reactionary conspiracy
theory yes
but having said that like this is like
an irish person coming out and being
like in america irish people
need to have irish roles like
we are so close to my dream
of italian people coming out and being
like we need more italian representation
over here valley and forward yeah yeah
like
like something that i have been
ironically advocating for
we're so [ __ ] close to it now like i
want that so bad italian representation
yeah what the [ __ ] going on
you're selling cappuccinos i mean that's
all [ __ ] yeah exactly it's like that's
it's true okay so here we have the clip
i'm actually we can it's good we can
hear it and decide if she's kidding or
not but let's analyze this
okay let's see
just watch
jew face
doesn't feel good to say
is defined as when
a non-jew portrays a jew
with the jewishness
front and center um often with makeup or
changing of features big fake nose all
the new yorkie or yiddish inflection
and in a time when
the importance of representation is seen
as so essential and so front and center
why does ours constantly get breached
even today
people are people get mad when like
there's that [ __ ] show where there's
an indian actor uh the nation of al or
something it's an afghan interpreter who
like lives in america with a veteran
like people get mad at that chuck
laurier or whatever show right because
it's like the most bazingafied [ __ ]
uh you know insane american imperialist
agit prop you can see
um and the dude is like indian he has
like an interesting accent the writing
is like kind of [ __ ] dog [ __ ] people
get mad at stuff like that because
representation of like marginalized
communities is uh
important because one
it allows people to see themselves in a
role in a position of power in a movie
and that's important there's at least
empirical evidence for this
but also
you get to craft uh you get to be able
to write authentically about the said
experiences right
but if there's like
but
as far as like uh jewish representation
goes in hollywood i'm shocked well so
actually this is gonna be interesting
she she specifically named like uh the
fantastic miss mazel what was that show
called
marvelous miss me so marvelous miss
mabel i guarantee you and i i can't
guarantee but maybe you guys you guys
can easily fact check this
the creator of that show has to be
jewish
uh
right but the the actress isn't
the actress isn't jewish but my point is
right the character
i'm assuming
if you guys can fact check that why is a
[ __ ] comedian who did like blackface
and [ __ ] back in the day
and you know portrayed herself as hitler
and all this other stuff
now talking about like social justice
through comedy i i'm sorry this is like
the one area where i'm just like well
people are allowed to change their
opinions on stuff i know but like it
seems
the fact that she did blackface doesn't
mean that she can't ever like uh
make a try to make a point about
anything but but the question that i
have
is
do jewish lives matter to you as
hussein
hussein pecker no like i mean dude
this is like a tricky subject to discuss
because like there's a lot of nazi
propaganda yeah you know jews control
the media all that sort of stuff is like
ridiculous uh if there's anything
there's a [ __ ] wasp supremacy going
on in america forever but like no one
ever talks about that um cause you know
that's they make up the larger
percentage of the population um
but uh
i i don't know it's like the the one
area where there is like a lot of
authentic voices
uh that
can make fun of their own
marginalization their own struggles
their own history is like
jewish people uh in in the media
specifically right like i mean oh yeah
[ __ ] brilliant comedians
uh have have done an incredible job with
this so i i just find it
we saw a short clip but she goes on to
say
along with a lot of these portrayals
sarah says anti-semitic tropes are
stereotyped
and often played up on camera including
what she describes as prosthetics to
make someone's nose bigger when has that
happened recently
i don't see that
yeah and a heavy new york accent with
yiddish undertones
the creator
uh
is half jewish
jewish on on her dad's side which
technically means she's not just no
that's i don't know
i mean but like it's maternal it's
interesting yeah i mean do you agree
with this i mean you don't no no i i
don't think there's a representation
problem with jews in hollywood obviously
and entertainment at all
but i've never watched something and
been like
it no i've never thought about this i
don't care about this i think i don't i
but i think
i guess i see where she i think she just
sees like the representation and she's
like well what about the jews but i
don't really see that there's an issue
there well that's why i say like it's
like irish people in 2021 being like
yeah why don't you aren't irish people
playing irish people it's like
half the [ __ ] hollywood cast is like
australian sexy portraying themselves as
americans
i personally think that
a good actor can play i can play any
part and i don't necessarily have a
problem obviously if you're like
switching races that's [ __ ] weird
yeah
like scarlett johansson playing a
japanese woman yeah like well that's uh
who's jewish by the way
is scarlett's jewish yeah i did not know
that bro
um i love when i learned that like a hot
chick is jewish it's just like
you're like damn there's a lot of hot
chicks because
because it means like i could have had a
chance with her is that how that works
kind of you could have chosen scarlet
joy i think so
because the jewish thing holds a lot of
weight when you meet a hot jewish girl
it holds a lot of weight well
she is married to colin jost who is not
jewish yes so that's what i'm saying i
would have had a leg up oh oh okay i
would have had a leg up so that doesn't
show that her preference is uh going
after no it means she's settled i mean
she settled for a [ __ ] boy i love
this yeah
she and she could have done so much
better with her very happy he could have
been so much better than unhappy instead
scarlett's a full-blown jew yeah she's
ashkenazi
damn i know we our babies would have
been all [ __ ] up her original surname
is
schlamberg she dropped the schlabner
yeah this
i need representation i need more
schlumbers in hollywood yeah that's
there's another product i mean that is
actually unironically a consequence of
anti-semitism is like so many jewish
people changing their last names for
sure like that's definitely a thing to
but that
that kind of implies everyone again
the the [ __ ] wasp supremacy of the
whole ordeal where it's like
you know uh people coming from like more
marginalized backgrounds
meaning white white anglo-saxon
protestants yeah exactly the thing is
that that's the real standard so if you
go to the industry and you see like
there's you know jews
there's a lot of jews represented then
it's like dude wasps own everything like
still per capita you know there's more
[ __ ] wasps in charge in hollywood and
entertainment by far of course what the
[ __ ] that that's why it's like laughable
when people like that's why the
anti-semitic tropes are laughable i mean
there's like there is definitely
uh an over-representation
uh with respect to like uh you know how
many people
with respect to the demographics overall
but it's the same thing exists for lgbt
members and it's not like a conspiracy
it's that that's what people that were
marginalized gravitated towards as an
industry that doesn't [ __ ] imply
anything no innocuous or not innocuous
sorry it doesn't imply anything like
[ __ ]
scary or creepy or whatever the [ __ ] but
i think people are just
i don't know i guess but there's also
something like
i don't know anti-semitic
thank you keemstar we knew that keemstar
is anti-semitic oh yeah he once told all
of his followers to uh
tweet at me death to all jews
i'm sorry what i swear to god he did
that that's [ __ ] insane he did it he
said everybody go tweet h3 death to all
jews
that is okay that's
yeah do we have uh we have a clip of
that yeah he did it on video
there's a video i mean he's done a lot
on video oh yeah i'm just saying like
it's never it's never enough for someone
like keemstar hates the jews
oh yeah so but like there is an
interesting thing though
about white people or like passing white
in the case of scar i mean two white
whatever
uh she's white but like
tom cruise in the last samurai you know
that's like some real white savior [ __ ]
it's a great movie
yeah it was i loved it yeah it was a
good movie actually yeah i like that
movie too but then tom cruise is a
scientologist so that's representation
that matters there that is right nordy
religion yeah i don't think the last
samurai was scientologist though but
i get your point
[Laughter]
um
and then scarlett playing ghost in the
show
so it's like but as an anime i see why
people wanna want like asian
representation there but
i don't even i mean i personally think
it's like funny i don't
i don't think that's like
you're not fixing anything there so what
representation does matter at what point
representation absolutely matters when
you center black voices in a black story
instead of doing like [ __ ]
weird like white savior movies like
every [ __ ] every black trauma porn uh
always revolves around like some [ __ ]
white person that's like
the good white you know what i mean sure
why people love feeling really good
about like how how
there were some good whites out there
during uh the the you know civil rights
movement or whatever good one yeah yeah
it's like i don't know but
uh 67 of the country thought mlk was
like a terrorist so i don't
in the aftermath really death even so i
don't think you would have been one of
the good ones i don't know statistically
you have been one of the bad ones yes
exactly um especially if you're like a
ben shapiro or a [ __ ] stephen crowder
you're like the worst white player oh
you would have [ __ ] um you would have
been spitting on him but yeah yeah
whiteness is a expanding concept it's
not real it's built upon the it's built
upon the concept of exclusion if you go
to nazi germany jews were definitely not
considered white neither were slavic
people why yeah the white the jewish
money to me
i am considered white here in america
for sure but like if you ask a you know
a white supremacist if i'm white yeah no
they would say
no
we're in the same boat there because
like pale as a [ __ ] so like i'm
super white passing muslim turkish but
like
you know directly from the caucus
mountains almost right yeah um but if
you ask like uh
you ask a white supremacist i'm you know
i'm i'm saying i'm hussain pecker yeah
exactly yeah [ __ ] now
yeah it's is it interesting but it was
interesting yeah if you ask the white
supremacists don't want me
i just
like
here's the reason why i brought up the
black face right your position can
absolutely change on issues that's why i
do what i do i believe that people have
the capacity to change my positions
certainly have over the years they've
evolved
but like
it's kind of strange where like
comedians will [ __ ] exhaust like edgy
comedy to
its
you know maximum allowance basically
and and i don't have a problem with that
ultimately especially if it's funny if
it's not then you know that's a
different subject but
uh but then they turn around and now
it's like the tide has turned and like
everyone is doing this like corporate
friendly we're all brands
uh and and representation matters in the
like aesthetic side
uh attitude so now it's like it just
seems disingenuous you know what i mean
especially when it comes to
representation in hollywood for
uh portrayals of like jewish people or
jewish people in general it's like
i mean i i feel like it's i don't know
the thing is it's it's like a non-issue
that you brought up that's the thing and
it almost like takes away it's not that
funny either yeah and it takes away from
like
you know real problems with
representation when it comes to like
black directors
and
like the the areas where like
representation matters is where the
areas where
you know black and brown people do not
make up uh even
like any significant
percentage of writers rooms or or
uh producers or or you know in front of
the camera
and that's what that's why i'm like what
the [ __ ]
it's just
so
yeah and
right so in in short but like yeah i
mean
but at the same time she just talked
maybe she's just talking and thinking
out loud on her podcast so maybe maybe
people are looking too much i don't know
yeah but ju face just sounds funny i
think yeah it's funny the concept of ju
face is funny
and she as a comedian i like that idea
yeah but then you guys are curious about
it yeah
and then it ruined the whole thing
because i loved you face
it's just like hit me too like you could
say
there's so much room with you face
you know like i have a friend he looks
jewish but he's not
yeah jew face
yeah he's doing jew face he gotta
[ __ ] take care of that he's getting
he's getting the privilege of being a
jew
like scarlett if god forbid scarlet
cross fats with them and should be like
this man's jewish i'm gonna take a shot
that's not fair you're done yes you're
out representation yeah he deserves
colin josh we're coming after you dude
leftovers podcast
i've been trying to find uh
evidence of of a recent movie where
somebody used prosthetics to to make
their nose
this is the only example i could come up
with
was in the movie cloud atlas the actress
halle berry who's a black woman in one
of the plot lines that's played a jewish
woman not halle berry that's how they
bury him makeup what wow that's really
good that's good
spectacular wait she's playing a jew
yeah if you're familiar with cloud atlas
it's like it people being reincarnated
in a bunch of different ways but so in
one of her she's why would they cast her
to play a white woman i didn't know it's
in it's an alternate universe it's part
of
you kind of have to see the movie she's
not herself oh she's a black woman
one alternative oh well that makes one
alternate timeline i'm not gonna get
more about that you
but it's like it's like getting mad at
dave chapel's white face you know what i
mean it's like what the [ __ ] yeah
totally
which i love by the way yeah so [ __ ]
funny and that's that's kind of my point
which is that like one thing that i
personally get like very upset about
even though ultimately i think like
attacking culture
uh in this way is is unproductive
overall
uh but one thing i get upset about is
like i'll beat them up people from
marginalized backgrounds whether they
are jewish
whether they are black brown like
they
make incredible content
um
making jokes about
said marginalization and said oppression
and said struggle and i think that
that's where like
there's beautiful art that comes out of
it you say jews are are marginalized
yeah oh thank you but i don't i i no but
i mean like whose in america are
marginalized no but i mean there is a
shitload of anti-semitism dude i mean
there's still [ __ ] there's a lot of
anti-semitism people [ __ ] hate my
guts for being jewish yeah but then what
i'm referencing is like
intergenerational trauma uh as a
consequence of the [ __ ] holocaust you
know what i mean yeah so
there is a lot of i mean
jewish people are are
becoming better off uh over the over you
know multiple generations now and i'm
not comparing it to black trauma at all
but there is a
there is a shared struggle there as a
consequence of anti-semitism that
creates [ __ ] awesome art yeah and in
a lot of instances they're making fun of
you know their own stereotypes and [ __ ]
like that and it's [ __ ] funny it's
like you're right that's what it
is and i hate policing that where i'm
like why are you know why are you doing
that yeah like that's crazy
[ __ ]
like the nanette style
uh
comedy policing so that like every joke
or every comedy special needs to turn
into a [ __ ] ted talk it's like
don't rob the [ __ ]
last remaining like
uh thing that is humorous on this planet
by the way speaking of anti-semitism
he was serious like seriously everybody
tweet at [ __ ]
h3h3 death to all jews
there you have it
that's wonderful classic [ __ ] right
there buddy that's keemstar we love that
for him yeah it's good yeah i woke up
one day and i was like why is everybody
wishing me death i was like psych i get
that every day
he's like another day
he's like i thought it was a normal yeah
i thought it was tuesday [ __ ]
yes so i've got um
how long we've been going dan uh about
an hour and a half and okay it is noon i
don't know if uh hassan we can keep
going because we started a little bit
late okay
yeah another i've got my right wing
cringe comp that i want to go this is
kind of like my fun part this is the fun
part of the show yeah so alex jones as
you heard lost his lawsuits on a
technicality what a [ __ ] idiot yeah
my theory on that alex jones failed to
provide documents during discovery over
the course of years of the judge saying
you need to produce you need to produce
you need to produce and him ignoring
court orders for years so this wasn't
like some [ __ ] judgment this was
they gave him as much time as reasonable
possible and because he failed to
produce documents he lost all of his
lawsuits
uh which he i think he would have had a
good chance of winning it's the weakest
way to lose a lawsuit man can't do it
the only way i have of explaining why he
failed to produce documents is because
if wha if what he had to produce would
have made would have been so [ __ ]
damning
to his reputation
that what reputation though i mean he's
defended himself as like in divorce
court he's defending himself as like the
things i say are actually parody and not
meant to be taken seriously no carlson
has done that too no the things that he
must have said oh yeah he's so horrific
behind the scenes that he was willing to
take the biggest l
of all time
oh 100
i know i know for a fact uh that
he he
hates that like he
he does not like the mentions of sandy
hook he like
he's trying to get past it yeah he's
trying to move past it he's
demonstrating growth yeah well so here
he is demonstrating growth uh this is
from
what's today this is from two days ago
uh right-wing pastor
tony spell calls in
and i love that they are agreeing that
the covid vaccine is part of satan's
plan to depopulate the earth
facts facts no printers they're gonna
have the answer for all the chaos and
turmoil and and the weather problems
that are are actually being controlled
right now by i was about to say they
have a huge secret government weather
control program at the u.n they admit
exist i love all the
documents the [ __ ] desk like straight
up like charlie day with the conspiracy
board on his desk i mean
we did steal his set design
yeah and we do it better this is a three
million dollar set
from the back i got no documents in
front of us i'm just oh my god bro
i have a laptop in front of me i don't i
don't he's got the fanciest [ __ ]
studio and he's printing out like that's
why he has the overhead camera to like
show
uh you know what documents he's looking
at it looks like such a boomer though
and the documents are literally like a
printed out breitbart article
why are you printing articles yes i got
the documents right here you've got to
start pinching pennies with those
lawsuits uh settlement spencer stuck in
a ding-dong
so um
yeah apparently the vaccine is causing
also the weather uh problems we're
experiencing uh everybody knows that
there might be something else causing
the extreme weather
but it could also be the valley no it's
the event also the gaze oh yeah it's u.n
climate control
um and not climate change which is fake
and a chinese comedy propaganda yeah
there were some great ones where the uh
i think
gosh it was one of the classic uh
pastures was when the hurricanes were
coming around it was he was blaming the
gays
oh oh rush limbaugh i think did that
russian ball did that um
he also he also said it was fake and
then hurricanes never happened and then
and then they caught him leaving the
state that's a i see rush limbaugh used
to does it like no one done it yeah that
[ __ ] said hurricanes aren't real
yeah while evacuating yeah that's what's
up yeah that's that's that's what i'm
talking about like that's high level
i mean i laugh at his death every day
yeah i mean it's great
yeah cord rings peas in his basement but
rush limbaugh
well i don't know what's the comparison
i just wanted
his basement again what humans are made
out of so you're bad exactly they're
orchestrating the global depopulation
collapse and they're going to blame it
on again the general public why does
satan want depopulation
he wants the population because he wants
revenge against the human race because
we took his place they're saying this
like they know satan yeah like i've i
had a long conversation also he knows he
might be satan these people need to be
on anti-psychotics not [ __ ]
television yeah no i'm an advocate for
bringing back lobotomies for evangelical
pastors dude no
lobotomies it's like dude if this guy is
leading your congregation like that's a
l like how do you [ __ ] sit there and
listen to this [ __ ]
psycho like just he looks first of all
because he makes so much sense bro he
looks evil like i don't understand it
that's why that's what's so funny to me
about like writing kenneth copeland is
the most safety yeah like [ __ ] these
[ __ ] literally look like the
devil yeah and you're just sitting there
being like yep that's right
and he's going like the devil is among
us yeah satan might be right in front of
your nose right now yeah what are we
going to do what are we going to do god
made man in his image and after his
likeness the sh the shot actually
affects
your dna the oxygen nucleic acid it
actually changes the
structure of humans who are created in
god's image and after his likeness you
could trust me i'm sitting in in front
of a bunch of books that's right he read
all of them the vaccine changed the dna
i asked satan he said it to me i know
him very well okay let's play the game
you think he's vaccinated
they're all vaccinated
i don't know some of these dudes
especially at that level some of them
are like the right-wing uh right-wing am
radio host they just [ __ ] die
nah he's vaccinated yeah you guys have
too much to lose i was about to say he
probably has a lot of money he's got a
lot of money he's loving his life he's
in on the griff we're all backstage what
about alex he's vaccinated do you think
so oh yeah yeah oh one hundred percent
suspect they're all vaccinated all the
fox new guys are vaccinated yeah we know
that yeah they're the only people who
aren't vaccinated are the people that
watch their show
you know well the am radio uh hosts uh
like are all around the country that
like you know those guys are not
vaccinated yeah but they're not rich
am radio hostels [ __ ] still
make money [ __ ] yeah they do man
name one name one um i mean i don't know
any of them by name because i'm not a
psycho but i don't like those i don't
think those guys make money anymore dude
they still reach to like a gigantic
audience someone look up like the
biggest conservative am radio host and
let's do some i mean like rush limbaugh
is like he's he's rush limbaugh right
yeah but even then like he had do you
think he was facts
was he vaxxed
probably i mean he had he was [ __ ]
cancer so he didn't want to
he didn't want to die he's vac yeah so
one of the
one of the radio hosts that died of
covet recently this guy bob enyart who i
guess was fairly big
um it says his net worth was about a
million so you know not crazy money it's
not crazy that's like he's doing well
i don't think so bro i don't think radio
guys make money anymore well yeah
hassan's right though that this is
probably just like a relatively small
just look up i don't care if they
want to know how much money these
[ __ ] are making right wing yeah am
radio
broadcasters wealth
that's good
the world's highest paid radio host of
2018. i mean it's gonna be like [ __ ]
howard stern and [ __ ]
yeah
he's on serious oh
yeah no it's his highest paid howard
stern earnings 90 million rush limbaugh
84.5 ryan secrets 74 sean hannity 36
million these glenn aren't on radio
glenn beck these guys
they have radio shows yeah but they're
not making their money from being am
radio host glenn beck 8.5 million are
all huge network stars yeah glenn beck
is like one of them
8.5 million so but this is what i mean
on tv beck is still one of the most
popular radio talk shows in america with
an estimated 10.5 million listeners damn
yeah but has never trump stance harmed
his bottom line
so that's why
they never trump [ __ ] up about that yeah
you gotta keep your mouth shut on all
that yeah most of his money comes from a
seven figure radio contract with
premiere okay
well he passed his paycheck with book
earnings and low returns from his
struggling media company the blaze damn
forbes [ __ ] ripped him struggling the
blaze yeah
here another another uh am radio host
that died of coven mark uh
baroneer bernier i guess yeah
his net worth about four million so you
know again that's not money
right yeah that's good money that's
right dude that's a [ __ ] daytona
beach
so that's a daytona beach talk show host
you know what i mean he's got a [ __ ]
radio show
how the [ __ ] does he have four million
dollars and then you look at his like uh
you know you look at his audience
and you realize like oh my god these
dudes loki still command like a pretty
sizable [ __ ] audience yeah
conservatives are hogs man they consume
they find their boys and they consume
man it's pretty impressive
if we were conservatives man we'd be
[ __ ] i know it bro that's why i
always socialist games yeah that's why
that's why i always [ __ ] laugh when
people are like ah he's using socialism
to grift it's like yeah that's why
there's so many [ __ ] incredibly
successful socialist broadcasters out
there yeah i think you're the only one
that's online there's like yeah there's
like three and we all get [ __ ] ripped
on non-stop by other socialists on the
internet and i could make what is this a
comparison oh how our set is more bomb
yeah
he knows he knows the truth he's the
dude that's sandy hook people are coming
our set is looking bomb he's rattling
he's gonna have america
ours is more patriotic first of all
that's right alex jones is uh a few
months away from peeing in his basement
i'll tell you what isn't that just
government is wanting to push this
vaccine so so heavily and say if you
don't take it we're going to it
literally marks your dna they're going
to have the answer yeah so yeah he's
still he's being good boy
this isn't being a good boy he toned it
down he's just saying that the vaccine
is a satanic uh yeah uh conspiracy to
kill everybody on earth oh 100
nothing but facts this is normal stuff
though you know this was a really
interesting take from the daily wire
host
who basically said
that uh vaccine mandates
the spanish inquisition is more
justified
than vaccine mandates no that's that's
wrong he's uh comparing it to cancel
culture
yeah
culture is less
i'll just let you listen to it it's
fantastic
as for the videos i hate that this is
ben shapiro's and he's got that look you
know what i mean he's he just looks like
a pet he's got that coil
all right this is the youth pastor you
want to apologize he literally does a
lot of [ __ ] sus [ __ ] too like he he
went to he went to like the [ __ ]
public meeting of the school board
his children are [ __ ] homeschooled
like what are you doing at the school
board meeting
children are [ __ ] homeschooled dog
what's wrong with you don't let this kid
around talking about [ __ ] crt and and
mask mandates for children it's like
mind your own business yeah you just you
know your children home you [ __ ] yeah
um so here's his hot take as for the
videos they demonstrate an important
point
that gender ideology more than any other
leftist doctrine
is spread and propagated by force
what you're witnessing in videos like
this is a modern form of forced
conversion
gender activists compel normal people to
affirm their doctrines under threat of
public shaming loss of income or
violence or all three in some cases in a
forced conversion centuries ago or even
today in some parts of the world you may
have been coerced into affirming a
religious doctrine under threat of being
burned at the stake
now you're coerced into affirming the
doctrines of the gender cult under a
threat of having everything else in your
life aside from your physical body
incinerated oh okay trans activists are
basically what your public school
history teacher told you the inquisitors
were
the difference is that the inquisition
you got this is my favorite part okay
okay we'll hear it right here
the difference is that the inquisition
has been caricatured i mean it was far
more defensible than modern day cancel
culture is the inquisition is far more
defensible
than cancel culture the inquisition was
straight up paranoid [ __ ] i respect
that i gotta be honest with you i
respect that i because like i hear
i hear dudes like defend the civil war
you know what i mean and that's like
you know i defend it from the northern
perspective sure no no no i'm talking
yeah no i'm talking like you know people
defending the confederacy like
that's [ __ ] that's broke [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] was like the inquisition
was defensible but his boss is ben
shapiro you don't hear that mass murder
jews yeah no you don't but you don't
hear that a lot no you never hear that
because my first reaction was like okay
what was defensible about the
inquisition
period or just mass murder her jews i
think that's what he's like that was
tight
yeah
pogroms not bad for him he's like the
real pogrom is cancelled culture so
what's your crazy statement i love
the
psychotic breakdown that has to occur in
your [ __ ] brain
to suspect that a [ __ ] trans person
is at the center of power in any
conversation like they are at the
intersections of marginalization yeah
you literally in numerous states can
[ __ ] get away with murdering a trans
person and use the gay panic defense
okay or the transpanic defense and like
and it happens all the time trans black
women go missing regularly nobody gives
a [ __ ]
no like nothing these are the most
powerless people like the most powerless
people yeah in in society right now so
powerless that you can openly talk about
their existence and just be like
yeah trans people are mentally ill or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say and
that's like normal conversations that
can take place you can't do that for any
other marginalized group in a similar
capacity right
and this [ __ ] has the audacity
to be like
they're the most powerful they're
they're leaving they want to kill us all
yeah they want to kill us all yeah and
actually you know the mass murder of the
of jews that took place the inquisition
well
that's defensive that's more defensible
than what they're doing yeah not just
jews they killed they killed all kinds
of people far more defensible he said
yeah so so what he's saying
therefore
is that we need to kill trans people i
mean that's what he's arriving at i mean
if they oppose that great of a threat to
us we need to eradicate them yeah it's
it's
absolutely insane but i like but i kind
of respect it like i say it's like
creative we i like and also like you
know let's not mince words here just
tell us tell us who you are i appreciate
that i guess it's a little scary
i feel like a lot of these dudes though
they they uh
they don't have a lot of people watching
them you know what i mean so they
succeed on that end because like who the
[ __ ] is watching matt walsh dude you
know i mean he's such a [ __ ] goober
like
like who's like man this i can't i gotta
get my daily dose i gotta get walter
right he's not yeah yeah like i don't
understand it for bench bureau either
but like he's demonstrably successful
you know unfortunately um
but uh matt walsh and like you know
michael knowles who i've debated in the
past
uh those guys are
they're the lackeys they're they're not
they're not he works for her i mean i
don't i don't know how many people watch
but he works for a big media company
yeah daily wire so it's not like you
know somebody they've coast they're a
huge company
they've co-signed him they put him on
the tv yeah face this is zuckerberg
approved content right oh yeah
oh yeah well zuckerberg once famously
said he
he
the holocaust denial which is like the
single telltale sign of a fascist person
uh was uh you know a difference in
opinion yeah i remember that yeah
fantastic insane like an insane thing to
say
this is a bro just a difference in
opinion bro like you know who says that
nazis is technically true yeah i mean
yeah yeah the difference in opinion is
that like you're a nazi
um is it true that i i was reading i
just heard this is it true that they
used to chant during executive meeting
at facebook company over country
i've never heard that but uh it doesn't
look that surprising and i swear that
sounds like urban legends but i swear
they used to i heard i just company over
country is what they
it immediately came up yeah i mean it's
there's a vox article i was zuckerberg's
speechwriter companies over countries
was his early motto company over country
they used to chant that
dude this these freaks i mean they they
literally
they control the internet in a lot of
developing nations like they offer free
internet in what is known as a walled
garden uh internet and it was actually
struck down in india but i think a form
of that still exists like latin america
communications almost exclusively rely
on whatsapp you know like these guys
like
they are more powerful than countries
they're so much more powerful than
countries
they're more powerful than multiple
countries at this point that's the
problem with that level of wealth you
know well also that it comes at the cost
is so much below there's so many
problems with that a new book reports
that mark zuckerberg emphasized a
company over country mantra in his
company's early days yeah so was that
just his mantra or was he literally
making his employees chant that because
that's some serious well i mean both are
regardless this [ __ ] literally
thought to himself
company over country yeah he's probably
not alone and he's like that's my
guiding star
i'm the meat chef it's awesome
yeah no i uh we got to bring back
[ __ ] tech serfdoms or well i mean we
got to bring back serfdoms and make them
tech serfdoms you know disruptive
very disruptive new idea called uh you
know having peasants
they don't looking script to [ __ ]
fight for you it'll be awesome when you
go to war with like i don't know [ __ ]
microsoft yeah microsoft
yo i know we're getting a long time so
i'm gonna rapid fire here's ted cruz
he's sending his thoughts and prayers to
the victims of a school shooting but
more pressing issues he's here to talk
about and there have been far too many
of these at far too many schools and so
we are grateful for the courage and
heroism the first responders
and we are hopeful that that all of the
students
or individuals
who may have been injured will will come
through
and survive
we're here today
because of the biden border crisis
that continues to rage on the southern
border oh my lord all right
oh wait wait wait they cut them they're
so like he's like we're here today and
then they [ __ ] cut his ass off it's
so good
all right so we dropped in there to hear
a little bit of texas senator ted cruz
yeah and there has been
his own state this is in texas we know
he doesn't give a [ __ ] bro he ran to
cancun when the [ __ ] state ran out of
power yeah um and then blamed his
[ __ ] daughters who are massive
minecraft stands by the way i'm almost
100 certain that ted cruz's daughters
are like woke as [ __ ]
that'd be great no they they straight up
they might even watch this show i i
i i'm not shout out ted cruz you know
what i'm saying shout out to reach out
no
they found his dad um the zodiac killer
yeah they found him well he's the zodiac
killer his dad killed jfk bro he's the
zodiac killer yeah yeah that doesn't
mean
i think that doesn't make any sense time
continuum wise this is donald trump baby
don't matter
okay um but yeah no his his daughter's
um almost certain because he he actually
said a happy birthday dream he liked
tweet oh yes
yeah i sent it on discord and uh
you're gonna hate his guts yeah his
daughters well they already do that's
for sure yeah yeah happy birthday big
fans of all the minecrafters and shout
out to the cruise family your dad's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah no for sure like i i
think that they know though like i
there's no shot you could be like a
[ __ ] minecraft stand and
not like realize that your dad kind of
sucks well he made those weird family
videos too when he was running for
president you remember the super his
daughter was there like don't touch me
dad you have tonsil stones well he also
constantly [ __ ] shits on him like
he's like yeah i went to cancun because
my [ __ ] five-year-old daughter wanted
me to go dumb [ __ ] daughter wanted to
go to cancun she forced me
oh you replied to that oh i i just
noticed that right below
the top
you fell off
permanently out for texas plus ratio
yeah that's good can i am i lost it
like taker's existence
well you see how much he cares about
texas my this is a school shooting that
happened in texas my thoughts go out to
the families
anyway it's but like here's the thing
dude it's just done in america it's so
commonplace that like dude remember back
in the day they used to say like don't
make this political don't make this
political you know and now they're just
like yeah who gives a [ __ ] yeah thoughts
and prayers whatever let's move on to
the real anyway yeah yeah the border
crisis
here's a suggestion just don't be
[ __ ]
yeah because exactly is that bad that's
ted cruz
yeah interesting thought
yeah so that's a good one i really like
anyway
uh
let's see
lindsey graham booed by his own
supporters for saying suggesting they
should get the vaccine
uh fantastic they've oh no
not like this freaking not like chinese
uh censorship right there dude yeah so
the the conservatives have uh created a
monster that they've lost control of
they've created a monster that is now
eating
their base and
it's killing so many people now uh in
the south and in red states now it's
almost entirely people are dying by like
80 in red states and it actually
i mean we just crossed like seven
hundred thousand deaths now yeah and you
remember dan i said this this pandemic
could kill a million people and thought
uh people literally thought i was
psychotic scaremonger
and here we are on the precipice but now
it's just killing mostly conservatives
and i think they are realizing they may
have [ __ ] up with playing games with
this here's well the thing is i don't
think they care about their
voters dying necessarily because like
the conservative they care about losing
well
their strategy does not revolve around
like uh you know democracy anyway and
they always work from a minority
position
um and they have already set like new
voting restrictions in like 19 states
immediately
uh through republican legislatures
already that will totally obliterate
voters protections
so they can always win with a minority
that doesn't really matter they can
always stop people from voting
and make it as hard as possible for
people to vote i think the real problem
here is that like i see user packed
and uh the workforce is dying
and we can't go back to like a normal
order of the economy still especially in
like red states and stuff like that
and that's why they're like panicking
they care more about you know capital
and they care more more about the
interest of capital than they do about
like
losing voters because their
their strategy
doesn't really rely on winning votes
their strategy relies on making sure the
other side can't vote
poor people can't vote black people
can't vote
so but the truth is even with the voter
suppression and working from a minority
position the margins are slim they're
still slim dude
like you you've lose a couple thousand
people on the wrong place by
i mean yeah but you lose a couple
thousand people but then you stop ten
thousand people from being able to vote
you purge them for the ballots you make
it so that like there's no mail-in
ballots you know stop all of that
immediately
and boom all of a sudden you you yeah
they're they're changing
they change the balance again well
here's lady graham um
trying to introduce people
[Applause]
in that crowd dude i hate these [ __ ]
videos yet thank you are the people in
the hospitals in south carolina and
vaccinated
wrong you're wrong
i read on facebook mark zuckerberg said
that's a lie but that's not dan can you
just find there i hate this i hate it
cnn but like music over it but like why
are they saying wrong to that it's true
like how are you because i read on
facebook
but then that their hospitals are
actually empty the funniest part about
it is like whenever they turn around and
they go
there must be another conspiracy why are
all these anti-vaxxers dying someone's
murdering them
it's like yeah oh yeah yeah exactly yeah
it's great it's great
i read that the hospitals are empty and
i my friend joe's cousin went out there
and went into he went into the hospital
and it was empty
and then he died of covert the next week
yeah he was assassinated yeah that's
that's the wonderful part about it is
like you know four of my family
immediate family members have died and
also kovit is still fake
and don't get the vaccine yeah it's
great man no keep it up like i don't
care if you're going to a [ __ ]
lindsey graham rally like and you're you
know 65 year old piece of [ __ ] like if
you die because you didn't get the
vaccine i literally do not care those
are like
your time here that your time has come
okay your time has come you're gonna
[ __ ] die
sucks to suck at this point like i've
given up on trying to vaccinate those
people what i do care about is like you
know poor people that are victims of
misinformation
that are working all the time
don't have immediate access to like
medical facilities things like that here
we go
love if you haven't had the vaccine you
want to think about getting it because
if you're my age
boom
i didn't tell you get it you don't think
about it
[ __ ] you i won't think about [ __ ]
92 of the people in the hospitals in
south carolina unvaccinated
wrong [ __ ]
my cousin jeb works at the hospital
that's wonderful
it's [ __ ] awesome isn't it it's a
death cult like they they are suicidal
they straight up like there is no i
don't know how else to look at this
other than that
um we've done two hours
damn so much great stuff i know it was
like do i have time for one more video
i mean if you make it real quick but we
are out of this one's really fast uh
anti-vaxx protest in l.a or new york
sorry destroys oh yeah a coveted testing
site for no [ __ ] reason yeah
wonderful stuff
they're protesting the vaccine uh hello
protesting the vaccine
and tearing down what the [ __ ] kind of
is that tearing down a testing station
yeah are we those are the real villains
of society people that want you to get
tested
are we against testing now that's what
i'm saying like it's like they're not
even like doing mass vaccinations there
dude they're literally just testing you
for covid like you're like
no thinking about covid anyway here it
is it's fantastic
i i always assumed that they should be
in favor of the testing sites especially
because like these testing sites are
helping homeless people poor people on
their commutes like
you know run by [ __ ] volunteers it's
psychotic
[Applause]
no testing damn it
well do you know who this protest was
so these are new york uh teachers and
educators that refused the vaccine and
got fired that's what this protest was
over damn it i'm just mad at the irony
the irony there is that like
the wonderful irony there is that like
the the new york mandates also
originally had a carve out for testing
like you either get the vaccine or if
you don't get the vaccine you get tested
on a weekly or i think maybe on a daily
basis
and uh so them destroying a vaccination
center is
oh you're not a vaccination sorry them
destroying a [ __ ] testing center is
additionally ironic
that's like the one way to know a lot of
people say like oh well you see people
are mass uh resigning it's like you know
it's like five percent or something
minuscule of the yeah but it's like dude
you're around children you're a great
part of society get vaccinated bro and
if you don't go find another [ __ ] job
i don't know what to tell you
it's it's wild the show
two hours yeah fist bump
in my trash can i'm gonna pee in my
basement all right yeah me too
thank you hassan
it's been another leftovers
in the trenches fighting for you
true patriots on america front looking
on the front looking at the juiciest of
hogs
[Applause]
take those hogs to market boy they're
ready for slaughter
best in show
that's right
do we
never salute
i mean never always hold